Master but as a remake and over the
weekend of PlayStation experience we saw
some more of that remake alexa ray korea
anthony carboni peter brown who's
excited for Final Fantasy I'm gonna
defer to the Final Fantasy scholar here
yeah there's another one we got there 25
are you a final fantasy scholar as well
I would say so I don't agree but I don't
know you the way I know Alexa training
look cool we saw a bunch of Midgar I'm
for a reason to see first 20 minutes of
the game and the first dental chapter a
final fantasy yeah what's up episodic
content so subsequently I guess square
put out a press release that goes on
Sunday saying that part yeah the story
will be told across a multi-part series
with each entry providing its own unique
experience as Final Fantasy fans does
that ring alarm bells or does that sound
fine I so I go both ways I am so I am
NOT as Anthony is not the biggest fan of
final fantasy 7 okay it's a fine game
it's not the best one no but no I and
considering considering they've put out
the game and then they made this the
prequel the sequel the CGI movie the
spin a couple games that world has been
beaten into the ground and they've done
and they've just sort of it's all sort
of dried up to me but the fact that
we're going to get Final Fantasy 7 in a
different way in a different format
piques my interest yes cool I'd like to
see you if you can make this a fresh
experience yeah I'll play it also i'm a
final fantasy nerd so i will however
might worry with the episodic thing is
is it going to be something like what
tail tail does in which each episode or
part is self-contained because what
happens if say the first episode is all
Midgar and the second episode is pulling
a random whatever the canyon or
something if you want to go back and
complete the quests that you didn't or
do things that you didn't in Midgard
episode 1 can you go back to previous
content is it going to pile on top of
each other or will they be a
self-contained experiences because part
of what makes final fantasy so appealing
is that you have these vast worlds that
you can go back and do whatever do
whatever side quests when you want it
and a lot of people i know we were
talking about this earlier after you do
the story you spend the next 20 hours
grinding and cleaning up everything else
that you did
you in the game yeah can we do that here
I don't know I've played maybe I think
the first like three or four hours of
final fantasy seven only recently as
well this year so I'm not a scholar when
it comes to this peter is it the type of
game as well that you can sort of you
can drift forward into areas that you
maybe shouldn't early or does the story
very much sort of like unlock stuff its
lair there's a lot of side content that
people love even optional stuff like
getting Vincent or you see for example
but Chuck Bob reading reading oh yeah
get that gold chocobo golden saucer wait
what's your turn look you know I think
the fact that this is happening at all
is kind of a boon for people who
appreciate this game and while I would
love to have a faithfully recreated like
massive new version of Final Fantasy 7
i'm not kidding myself there's no way
square UNIX is going to do that
faithfully and a hundred percent but if
I can get really well-composed vignettes
that take me back to the game that I
really love and show it showcase it in a
new way and let me interact in that
world I'll be really happy now the fact
that they're charging a full price per
episode we don't know that yet okay well
the fact that it sounds like they might
be doing that anyway it is you know
that's concerning if it's something like
a telltale Game Wow like who can
complain at that point but when you say
VIN yesh that sort of Buckley no raises
alarm rings alarm bells am I can't tell
the difference looking at the two of
them side by side because that's like
that could mean that it's not the entire
game than I can say that this is just
like a you know three hour segments oh
you remember this cool part I'm going to
finally see Sam see here's the thing
most people never talk about Final
Fantasy 7 and how it relates to today
right so many games in the series are so
far like out of the realm of
possibilities i'm not saying materia as
a thing or that chocobos are real but
but what I know I know as much but he's
also not saying chocobos aren't real no
no we're not we're not drawing a
conclusion on chocobos my favorite
pokemon but this this game really at its
heart is about you know corporations
running a muck it is about exploiting
the environment it is about rebels
taking on forces that are insurmountable
to the common man and doing so in a way
that's destructive but also
revolutionary and I
those themes are really powerful and you
don't need this stuff like chocobo
racing to do that and frankly aim but
that is what I was 15 points good thing
though I love final fantasy 7 it is my
favorite game alongside tactics but at
the same time we still have the original
and we don't have been playing on
PlayStation 4 right now so if people
love as much as they say they do but
your money where your mouth isn't
playing you know but if if if we're
honest with ourselves we cannot expect
square to take a game that featured
pre-rendered backgrounds and create a
fully fleshed-out 3d world around it 121
for the price of one game no that's
totally not doing that yeah they said
they're gonna try to keep as much of the
content in as possible they're gonna cut
some stuff but they said they're also
going to be adding some stuff so I get
this feeling that they want these
episodes to be longer than just a few
hours I'm thinking they're thinking you
know maybe these are 20 hours apiece
maybe these are things that are worth
worth buying because it's the length of
an average game and I have to say if
somebody as a person sitting on the
couch who's not a fan of Final Fantasy
Senate who like I get it it is the game
that built the PlayStation I understand
why it has such a huge place in so many
people's hearts I never liked the game
but watching this the way they're doing
the way they're doing it with the with
the kingdom hearts / Final Fantasy 15
combat the way they're kind of like
making it new and making it a more
accessible game in a way that doesn't
seem to be taking away from the
aesthetic and the things that the fans
love I'm a like this version of Final
Fantasy 7 this may wind up being a net
positive right because everybody who
loves final fantasy 7 gets what they
want and I get a final fantasy 7 and you
get a final fantasy 7 that maybe you
make it past the first few hours right
you know maybe we all wind up liking it
a lot more it kind of takes this
dried-up world that you're talking about
makes it new again super job it's almost
super dry it's like it's like most
thankless job in development trying to
make this game because some people are
going to want it to evolve some people
are going to want it to be as true to
form as possible some people would be
happy with the new graphics and people
want just an up res version the purest
remastering you could possibly think of
and do you think that like you guys have
expressed sort of a bit more you guys
are okay with this changing it up a bit
you know in terms of gameplay in terms
of how its release all that sort of
stuff do you think the general final
fantasy found 20 years later is
be as accepting of those changes ah yes
and no I know there are a lot of people
that are or will be angry that this is
that it's episodic it's not they're not
getting final fantasy 7 remade a game
they're getting something in pieces and
I I've been on the internet and I have
seen the sad um don't go on the internet
don't know that is literally where all
the saddest there and there are people
out there that also like are like they
love final fantasy but won't play seven
the original cuz I think it looks bad
and they don't want to waste their time
with it mhm um I think that the people
that love the game for what it is will
play this and be like I'm getting
something I love like Peter said again
in a new way and yeah but I also can
definitely see people being outraged
about it personally if someone who's
like big fan of the series again not a
fan of seven um I I i really like it I
like give you give me final fantasy
anything that freakin like the chippy
final fantasy game world final fantasies
coming out next year and it looks like
it looks like a kids game I'm gonna play
because its final fantasy nerd that's
the name on it yeah forget it um I know
I can see this both earning a lot of
love but also so I kind of losing a lot
yeah well you guys have had your say now
it's up to the Internet let us know what
you think final fantasy 7 remaster
remake really make the remasters we made
remake we made we make meaning we make
you got it remain one of those is right
Final Fantasy 6 weeks out you thank you
excitedly disappointed put your thoughts
in the comment box below
you